my name is mabina prue i'm a developer
at conde nast
so uh
oh
it's working it is working i just don't
know how to use this all right so um i'm
a developer condens and um i'll be
talking to you guys a little bit about
bootshop today
just to show offense who here has worked
with bootstrap before
all right so there are
quite a few haven't worked with
bootstrap because i don't know you have
you haven't
you have worked with wichita for you
okay awesome this this talk is for
people who have not worked with
bootstrap because
um i think it's awesome especially if
you don't know what bootstrap is because
that's where i was i had heard of
bootstrap i just didn't know what it was
it was something magical that was there
to help you create awesome websites so
what is bootstrap it is nothing but a
nice open source
framework uh written for front-end
development by twitter so it comes from
a credited source if you log on to
twitter whatever you see on the front
end is actually written in bootstrap
um what it actually boils down to is
just a compilation of lovely css and
some jquery plugins they also have some
compilation of html templates so
to help you get started with your
website
so then you ask yourself why do you want
to use bootstrap what are some of the
use cases so these are the use cases
that i thought
i would use bootstrap for the first one
being not a front-end engineer which is
what i am i am not an engineer i've done
only back-end development for the
longest time
but every now and then you do come
across opportunities when you have no
choice but to do some front end
development
in my experience we had to spin up very
quickly a development portal to expose
our internal apis
and bootstrap just seemed to be the
obvious choice for everyone
i had to spend maybe a couple hours and
getting this development portal up and
ready and
trust me i'm not a
front-end engineer by any means i have
no idea how to write a nice beautiful
um css and
but that's where bootstrap came to my
rescue
second
use case would be something that i'm
thinking a lot of you can probably
associate with which is you just don't
have the bandwidth you don't have the
time you have
strict constraints but you still need to
develop a nice rich user experience uh
website so that's when bootstrap might
come to your rescue
and if none of these use cases apply to
you're this awesome front-end guru who's
you know sips on their coffee in the
morning and creates their own css grids
and writes these awesome
menu items and nav bars so you know why
use bootstrap because i can write better
framework than bootstrap it is great for
prototyping sometimes you just want to
whip out a quick prototype to get your
idea across so
that's when bootstrap can be helpful too
so now that we know there are things
that bootstrap provides let's look at
some of the core features that i had a
chance to work with so in my mind
bootstrap has like these two big
categories of things that it helps you
out with one is its ability to do page
layouts and the other one which is very
famous is its reusable components that
are these amazing css and jquery plugins
so you want to work with alerts nav bars
carousels
bootstrap has components for you
so let's talk a little about page layout
um
page layout is basically nothing but
a way for you to arrange your components
on a web page
um in a grid layout you do this using a
grid which is rows and columns this is
nothing new that bootstrap invented or
came up with long before bootstrap web
designers used to think about their
design in form of a grid put it on a
piece of paper take it to a web
developer and that's when you implement
it
where bootstrap really shines is in how
easy it makes it for you to actually
implement a grid system
so let's take a quick look at this
example um we have
three rows here
and this is a nine column grid which
basically means that every row span can
have nine columns
so the first
row here so i have three dibs the first
row here okay my first column needs to
span four columns how do i do this in
bootstrap you use a class a css class
called span four
it's extremely intuitive then look at
the second one um you have three offset
two so something special about this
column is i wanted to span three columns
but i needed to be a little bit to the
right so i want to offset it by two
again
what's the class in css for uh bootstrap
it's offset too so like the naming
scheme of these css classes is so
intuitive that it's you're not going
back and forth you once you've decided
what's the layout you're working with
you just start coding it
so a quick
example of this
right here we have
two rows the first rows are navbar
second rows are content so look at the
first row nav bar we using class row
let's
take a look in this one
we have one div that is spanning 11
columns and we wanted it to start a
little bit to the right so we gave it an
offset one that's it that's all i needed
to know if i wanted to move a little bit
further i would make this an offset of
two
this particular example is using the
default grid layout that comes with
bootstrap which is a 12 column grid
layout so the only thing i have to keep
in mind is span for every row should
just add up to 12. that's it
let's look at the second row
what do we have here okay so we have
three divs here
each one of them is spanning three
columns and the first one has an offset
of three so it's a little bit to the
right that's all i had to do to get all
these margins right and get the
get the grid system correctly laid out
oh gets better
and it's responsive
yeah
which is pretty awesome for me because i
was like okay i don't want to write any
media queries so this is awesome all i
have to do is drop in this file called
bootstrap responsive and
it works like magic
right
next is this component to me actually so
components is the piece that i was
talking to you guys before which is
another big feature of bootstrap that
people like using you can go on
bootstrap site and it's filled with
amazing components that you can use you
want to add
breadcrumbs nav bar drop downs it has
really good examples
markup you can use you can fiddle with
it they have some live examples so if we
go back to the example we were using for
our grid layout right in this example
there's at least
two components that are being used
one is the nav bar so if we look right
here
we're using the navbar component from
bootstrap and the first item in a navbar
happens to be this
fancy little drop down that again
is another
component from bootstrap
so i would just say spend some time on
bootstrap's component section and you
know i'm sure you'll find something that
is pretty useful for your website
um
all right so bootstrap's awesome but we
want more
if
you go on
google and literally just look for
bootstrap themes it's quite overwhelming
of how many themes people have written
for bootstrap
some are pretty awesome some are i don't
know you want to
play around with them before using it
the one that i used in the
development portal example that i was
talking to earlier was flat ui so if you
like the flat ui which is like the
microsoft surface look and feel um you
know go ahead and try that i actually
have an example right in that one
so this is using the default bootstrap
theme
i downloaded the flat ui
all i have to do is include the flat t1
css
let's refresh this voila
see these fonts change colors change
this was my favorite part you get this
nice lit drop down just by adding flat
tyre css
another site that i really liked was
bootswatch um it's basically an
aggregator has dozens of themes there
that you can just
look at some screenshots download it
play with it so that's pretty neat too
and that's about it so bootstrap ftw for
the longest time you used to think the
ftw stands for the what
you're like service down
so harassing corrected bootstrap for the
win download it
getbootstrap.com it has a great download
builder very customizable you wanna you
can overwrite the um the grid layout not
to be twelve columns fifteen columns
whatever fits your need if you have any
questions please feel free to email jp
john
palmers.com that's it thank you
all right uh goodnight everyone my name
is casey james uh i work at easybib.com
um
that's just a citation generator um
and it's the largest sub-citation
generator and i'm an ad operations
engineer there um i program primarily in
javascript
um but i do do a myriad of other things
which i won't get into here but tonight
i'm here to talk to you about not my
widgets um
here to talk to you about
ember jf
and uh this is gonna be a very high
level talk um
we're gonna touch on some technical
details um but we're gonna start out by
talking about um
how we got where we are today um
so not so long time ago um
2006 um to be exact uh john russig
concocted jquery here in new york um
and that opened the floodgates for uh
you know
easy
dot manipulation um you know prior to
jquery if you wanted to manipulate
anything in the dom
um
you know you were beholden to you know
cross-browser inconsistencies and a
number of other things um so that really
opened up the floodgates to
more consistent faster front-end web
development um an area that had been
neglected um prior to
2006. um so
yeah immediately following that uh you
know the web got into a rut uh we're
still talking about mainly uh
content oriented sites that uh you know
display things like text like blogs new
sites
um and a lot of uh
a lot of development uh with jquery on
the front end you know uh was centered
around replicating things that existed
with flash like you know those
lens flares slide shows things that are
like truly mundane uh things that we you
know beat to death on
on the desktop
um
so
in spite of these strides of
programmability um
the website's just remained websites
right um
you know we didn't
we didn't go back to the app like
functionality that we experienced um
through platforms like flash with flex
um we just sort of we're in a run
and at this point um between 2006 and
2010 um crafting app-like experiences
like gmail and google maps still takes
you know one of these guys to architect
a genius
an army of these guys devs to code um
you can see this guy he's like really
ready he's like oh yeah i'm gonna write
google maps
yeah um so you know
people from other environments are
thinking you know they're starting a
program on the web and they're like wait
we you know we've killed this problem on
the desktop we have no problem with code
organization
um we can do the things we want to do
um
and ultimately it boils down to
a number of things including um
a dearth of processing power on the
client side
um so
as a
as processing power on the client side
has increased
you know we have a broader range of
things we can do
smoothly on the client side
um
so as i said before the web was mainly
cons it mainly consisted of content
driven sites like blogs and news sites
um
so
yeah i think something is out of order
here
um
wow
so a
a paradigm
so on the web
um oftentimes
developers you know
you just write jquery you'd end up with
a bunch of callbacks and you'd have some
spaghetti and it's like you know how am
i going to maintain this you don't
really worry about that you and you just
you know come back to it when you
you know when you have to maintain the
application um
but in other environments uh
they're beholden to design patterns such
as mvc the model view controller um
which is the model view controller
paradigm
um
so
you know while all this is going on in
the front end um you know all this
development uh on the back end
you know these back-end engineers are
you know plowing through these problems
um
so in a traditional mvc web application
architecture
um you know the server takes care of
most of the
the
the part the moving parts of the
application so
um
i'm sorry uh
so for example things like rendering
templates and interacting with your
database it handles the gamut like if
you need to display a list of users you
know you'd write a a template which is
your view and a controller and it would
grab those things and it was a
monolithic um and it's a monolithic
architecture um
you know centered around clients that
have relatively low uh computing power
uh more recently what we've started to
see um is an alternative approach in
which the server side acts more as um
client i mean i'm sorry um
it's more service oriented um
and the front end taking on a lot of the
responsibilities that were held by the
back end
and that's what you're seeing you know
with frameworks like amberjs frameworks
like amberjs enable um
okay so i'm going on the wrong way with
that um
so what first and foremost what uh
frameworks like amberjs are are targeted
at doing is um
allowing developers to organize large
code bases
um that that's really what the
the goal is here right because prior to
that prior to mvc frameworks you know
the code your code is all over the place
um
so
i'm here to tell you what makes amber js
so awesome um and that's
you know there are a few key things such
as bindings computer properties
and auto updating templates
so
i'll just very briefly
go over bindings
so what we mean when we uh say bindings
um
is that we can have properties in our
our application that are linked um
together
um at the base level so for example here
we have um
in our app we have a wife
and wife has an attribute of a household
income
and
we also have husband and he has a
household income binding
um and it's bound to his uh wife's
household income
so that uh in our application when uh
the husband's uh household income goes
up
um the wife's household income also goes
um
and this this makes it easier to
you know you don't have to worry about
uh
updating your properties
in
with uh
you know prior to this sort of setup you
probably would have um you know ended up
with some sort of callback soup
um
so
i'll just very briefly show you um some
examples of auto updating templates and
uh computer properties so here we have
um a tool that i built that's a clone of
trello a few months ago
um
and we see that we have a account of
each of the cards on each
each board and um if i take this card
here and i move it along
to this board we see that the template
is automatically updated
with that value um
and i won't get into the technical
details of how exactly that works but um
these are just some of the things that
make
ember such a pleasure to work with um
okay
so uh before we go any further i'd like
to stress that um the purpose of a
framework mvc frameworks like emberjs
and angular is not to build
uh ordinary websites they're to enable
app-like experiences
um
so for like you know your typical blog
or
your new site you know you can
definitely um
you know throw those
frameworks at those problems but i
ideally you know
you don't you don't want to
um
you know use those frameworks where
they're applicable because you know you
don't want to use a hammer on a screw
right
so amber originated as a a fork of uh an
apple sponsored um
framework that set out to do the same
sort of things that amber does called a
sprout core
um
so yeah i'm gonna so now we're gonna get
into what you need to get started with
an ember application
um you'll need three things um at the
base level you need jquery 1.91
uh ember js 1.0 which uh just reached
that milestone uh not too long ago
um and handle rs 1.0
and you can all
you can find those at the amber um
mrjs.com homepage um
for all of you that for all of you that
use like package managers and things
like that um
i'm sure there's probably like a grunt
package or um
or something in bauer that you can
access that way but if you just want to
get started and you just want to fool
around and don't have to configure your
environment you can just head over to
amberjas.com and set that up
um
so when i was starting out i'd read a
lot of um
like posts uh by people that were
confused about um
amber and like um
you know the sort that you ran into the
whole source order problem when you're
writing your application and plenty of
you are saying you know amd what do you
what do you mean source order problem um
but yeah if you're just fooling around
um downloading that starter kit i just
mentioned should alleviate this issue
but if there's any doubt and you're
starting from scratch
um just you know keep you know note that
this is the order jquery handlebars
amber and then of course your
application
um
and your your base um
so when you're starting out your base
document looks very similar to html with
the exception of a few things
that we see here like um
these really funky looking brackets um
so what's that about um
so let's step back and take a high-level
view at uh the structure of an ember
application uh at its um view layer um
so
amber apps at the view layer are
comprised of a
uh templates components um the
applications router and its routes
uh models and controllers um now that's
a lot to take in um
okay
yeah um
but yeah these are the things that
comprise an amber app you know templates
would you know be
your view layer um
component
which is a bit more new um
which i want to get into too much detail
um
allow you to build essentially a
reusable components like for example
let's say you wanted to have a calendar
component that you wanted to be reusable
throughout your
your app you could um build that and
have it
i mean this calendar is sort of mundane
but um
i guess the example they have on the
site is uh
you know you entering your email address
and then
your gravatar
image being uh updated um
and then there's your application router
and its associated routes um
so the router is a pretty big thing
which i'll talk about um soon and and
then it wraps up with models and
controllers
um
so far that template we looked at looks
like a traditional website right um but
then we have this funky stuff that i was
talking about earlier um
and this is
a handlebars template um and
if a lot if any of you have done any
back-end development you'll see you'll
notice that it looks very similar
um to you know codes of code that you
might write in your you know back-end
erb template or or what have you
um
and uh this is how
uh your information makes it from
this is how your user is able to
interact with the models that you've
constructed in your app
uh so for in this example uh we have an
item in the model and uh you know we'll
iterate for as many
uh items are in that are in the model
and we'll display that in
in the interface um and it doesn't
modify the html file it this all happens
in dom um
so
so what exactly is the template in the
context of the number application um
it describes user interface for your
application and
each one of those templates that i
mentioned is backed by your model
so
like many other templating languages
templates can contain expressions
outlets and components and that
comprises the view layer
um so then there's the model layer um
which is very similar to um model if
you're familiar with it but it stores
persistent state so
you know things like a number of uh
visits or a number of emails or whatever
what have you um
it would be stored here um
while your application is running in the
browser now that
that is not uh
that that isn't necessarily the same as
um
you know what's stored in your database
but for the most part it usually lines
up with um
the the data structures you have therein
and i touched on the routes earlier so
routes help you maintain state in your
application
this allows your application to be
neatly segmented into states that are
easily reproducible by url so if you're
using this great app and you want your
friend to see a particular view that
you're in
it's as simple as you know copying the
url sending it off to your friend
and uh they'll be in the same place
you are in your application
uh so now i'm gonna just very quickly
walk through
um an application that was uh done by
tom dale of the core amber team it's
called blogger
and if i can just get this
to work because it seems not to want to
cooperate
okay
something is
not totally
here
sorry
i don't know what happened um
sorry um
wow
sadly i think we're out of time okay um
if there are any questions
um
feel free
so have you worked with amber with html5
history instead of the hash
uh no i have not okay because i just
started messing that
oh no i haven't used um
is that the recommended method or is
that an option
do they suggest using
so
um
i mean i i haven't seen any of my
tutorials i actually had it done with
uh history i've only seen it done with a
hash so then i started digging around
and
i found a way that
you know
there's an option i had to like look for
a readiness
and uh i was just messing around i was
wondering if you succeeded with it
oh no um
i mainly use the traditional routing um
like for example
uh
oh well uh this is a different version
of my application but i've normally used
the traditional routing
i've used it and enjoy it greatly
that's right i haven't worked with ember
i have worked a little bit with angular
and
a lot of what you covered seems very
similar just not surprising i was just
wondering uh i just had a very high
level uh is there anything that exactly
particularly shine over other nbc
javascript nbc frameworks any particular
feature that's like wow
um
well this is a
i think it's totally subjective but i
feel like um
a lot of the code generation that uh
amber
um does which i didn't speak about here
um because i feel like that's a little
um more in depth
uh is
it's very convenient like for example um
if you
create your model
um
a controller is also
generated for that model implicitly
um and it comes with a set of defaults
and i feel like that uh that accelerates
um
development in a big way would you want
to add any
uh sure so
my
my gut reaction to that question is that
the
pieces that amber gives you that are not
what angular also gives you because they
really do solve very very similar
problems are all around making sure that
you can't do things that shoot yourself
in the foot for example in angular
you're allowed to inject anything into
anything for if you want to have a
template helper that includes like what
happens to be in your route parameters
you can do that whereas ember like
refuses to you have to jump through
thousands of hoops and lots of hoops to
do things like that so ember forces you
down the the railsy opinionated way in a
lot of things and depending on what you
like i i enjoy that significantly
i believe you had a question and i sort
of have similar questions
comparing the pros and cons of other
frameworks like what you know why would
you pick amber over something else what
is it good at or what is it not as good
as very things like backbone or knockout
or
whatever
okay so you know background right to be
small you know simple hold on your
extras you know
controllers and routers right it's mdvm
oh
um
i i don't think i'm
qualified to answer that question
because i've only worked with ember
but if anyone else has
any
backbone doesn't have any data binding
built in at all
as casey said earlier ember is intended
to be for app-like experiences and
that's like a quote-unquote thing but
it's supposed to be
it is very very useful for applications
not just i want to read the blog post or
another blog post but rather i want to
interact with my data in a very very
like rich way and that because for
example it takes care of your url
completely for you and you don't have to
worry about you set up what's called a
router and when you hit refresh it knows
how to get data correctly for you you
have to do a no mapping that says like
if your parameter is user equals 12
something like that
i this is because i've it's sort of
fairly opinionated it does a lot of
things sort of automatically it has done
everything that i have done with bugs
and backbone multiple times and then
found more bugs in and then realized
that i'm so stupid and i don't know what
i'm doing i tried again
this is what amber has helped
one last question um
as far as amber goes
one common complaint i've seen is that
documentation isn't that great or
there's just not a lot of resources out
there to really help you get going i was
wondering if maybe there's
some good resources you guys could
recommend for people getting started oh
yeah definitely um
so uh i'll be giving uh jp um a link to
my uh
my slides at the very end there's a link
to a blog post that has a very extensive
um
number of uh
resources uh some of them not too up to
date um
i don't know one thing i've found about
the amber community is that they like to
rely a lot on um
on video which i really dislike because
i can't i feel like i have to you know
code at the pace of the video um
but there are
i think it's getting better but it's
still an area in which it's lacking
especially um like i've taken a
tangential look at um like the
documentation of angular and just i feel
it's light years ahead but it has
certainly gotten better
mean we're all in um and we spend all of
our time
going through the videos and catching up
on that and it's vocab doesn't do enough
for you yeah
phone cat is liking you version of half
behind now oh they've redone some of the
best practices which if you're
up to date on the mailing list right
you're up to date